The personal reflective
memo is a two-page document
that I ask the students to
write at the end of the class
but before the oral exam.
So all the lectures we've
had, all the team assignments,
and all the material
has been presented.
And at this point,
this reflective memo
asks the students to think
back on the material.
What really was the most
important thing they learned?
What of what they
learned in the class
are they going to build into
their own future projects,
their own careers?
If they're interested in systems
engineering as a career choice,
whether it's in research or in
industry, why is that the case?
And so they submit this one or
two days before the oral exam,
and so we have a chance to
read those reflective memos.
And usually, one of the
very first questions
in the oral exam is
about some key ideas
that they presented
in their oral memo,
so it provides a great
hook into the oral exam.